are you ready for some free video games
the March PlayStation Plus lineup has
just been revealed I'm Tony this is a
GameSpot news update and for all the
latest from Playstation be sure to
subscribe
first up ps4 owners are getting the
highly competitive frisbee throwing game
disc jam a brand new release making its
debut via PS + ps4 is also getting the
cutesy tearaway unfolded ps3 owners will
get to experience the bug slang
craziness of Earth Defense Force 2025
and the visual novel / fighting game
under night in berth PS Vita is getting
the first-person slasher severed and the
old-school style adventure game lumo
thanks to cross by you can also give
lumo a try on ps4 the new games will be
available on Tuesday March 7th so you
have until then to grab February's
freebies including LittleBigPlanet 3 and
not a hero for a look at another
upcoming game why not check out our
video on how ukelele resurrects banjo
kazooie's legacy and for all the latest
news and previews you're already in the
right place
you